let's talk some politics President Obama
had here to this guy
and he basically it out this week that
he's gonna be doing even more
executive orders is pretty much because
congressional Republicans refuse to work
with him or do anything
for the government so we have a
statement from Dan Pfeiffer
who is 0 bombers senior adviser given
this dynamic and what he's talking about
is how the republicans refuse to work
with President Obama president Obama has
only one option to use every outing is a
party to unilaterally improve economic
security
next week as congressional Republicans
spend their energy on yet another
partisan investigation
will be picking up the pace on executive
actions to help the economy
we have many more executive actions the
common everyday the president has charge
estimate looking for additional ways
to expand opportunity so he's talking
about the bank I think hearing that
Republicans are gonna do
I am I'm a little completed by this
because on one hand I think
that the republicans have been awful
they don't want to work with the guy and
is becoming the lame duck every day gets
closer to
to leaving and the other hand I don't
like one branch of government
sorta superseding what its power is
buddy
there's some great things though Obama
thing with our they executive orders
he's created 11 national monuments
I really think that that's the kind of
things yes the paper in there so is
likely the name are all just me being
unilaterally overstepping my bounds I'm
do it what to do
he's created up more than almost three
times as many national monuments is
George W Bush
to he did not know he's being very
effective in doing things like making it
even goes the cactus
in a in a place is protective will never
be never be taken apart but I II Q&A
with executive acted in an outlet like
that okay at least something's happening
the and its fine and
a it all comes down to like what is the
date overall dynamic
and you know if the Republicans are as
dedicated to stopping him from doing
things they say they are well then
they'll kinda find a way to overrule is
executive
at Borders yeah why don't think they can
overrule the executive order
counteracting pass something in order to
get that to happen but in the meantime
just go for it and do it
yeah do you really should he just do
this cuz he sorta has no choice or I'd
that bad in line well living and you
know these monument that is putting up
I must say that it interesting how you
kind of playing into the american people
would be
monuments because he's kind of like look
at this thing and while you're out here
let me talk about carbon emissions
because that's what you play and let you
know I
I mean you're getting people's attention
you're like a look at the giant
saying it's shiny and at the monument
that you love and while you're here I'm
gonna talk about various issues and
hopefully paper that and you know it so
I gotta give him credit for that and I
agree with you though I don't
I don't feel like I don't want to see
this become timetable dictatorship of
course but
you know I think I think politics is
kinda like this political whack-a-mole
happens you know it's like get people
don't do things are you taking executive
orders and then
the next guys gonna come and in the you
know be able to overturn the things that
he put in
so it it's just gonna happen but at that
these are headed down to tell about so
that nothing ever changed rather than
being fed you know franklin roosevelt
which it
with considered by many in 10 the most
popular president about time
in the amount executive orders that he
made what
Obama has done that was like his
afternoon tea time I have executive or
author you know right so they do go
crazy about later brought that up
because they go crazy cuddly on Fox News
about executive order
and you're right he hasn't done as many
other ways the other thing is that even
as many
as George Bush George W about equal but
you know george bush made some pretty
hefty executive order
having you know that will like them tho
etheridge or presidential
you know be able to hide things within
the president to you now iraq
yeah yeah things like that so no
so if this was a Republican right now
republican president you really in like
in the democrats were
stonewalling his all they would you be
more pissed about this the right now and
do it now
not really you being intellectually army
he'll actually on it I don't you know
when an aide
I'm one of those people really get up in
arms when it comes to like running
against each other
I like that more I think I fall in line
with most americans when it comes to
that end
and in terms of whack-a-mole like if you
need something big happens
there now say I can that specific thing
with terrible
but I don't think the average person is
you know and rightfully because they
have so much else to worry about
paying enough attention for this to
really kinda come to the forefront above
their daily lives so I kinda fall into
that I have way too much house was the
walk
I so it's me hear that how much farther
how much at this is just drama it's just
sort of this endless drama that they're
replaying over and over
and nobody believes what they're saying
they're just doubling down a party thing
the money
go it's all drama and there's always
like 1 it new movie that people are
using
you know there's always when when you
get to gridlock you have to do something
different
and in this situation the gridlock is
happening and so
the president is trying to do something
different to get around it
and just as when they were going head to
head trying to get things passed through
congress
people try different things that make
missus something he said well I can
actually do this
so I'm gonna go forward and do it I feel
like the republicans are gonna pouting
on the playground right now and he's
able while you're doing that
I'm gonna go handle business so you
can't be mad the
I like the accident and they have been
bidness midnight
up